all right another fake Grindhouse
trailer gets a real film adaptation I'm
[Music]
game so Thanksgiving first started out
is one of the fake trailers on Robert
Rodriguez and Quenton Tarantino's double
feature Grindhouse those fake trailers
were pretty awesome and that is in fact
where machete comes from and after what
seems like eons of production and years
of hearing about how Thanksgiving was
going to be an actual movie Thanksgiving
is now in fact an actual movie and I got
to be honest the beginning of this movie
was actually kind of brilliant it's
Thanksgiving evening Black Friday is
upon us because as addressed in the film
as well as as seen in real life Black
Friday starts on a Thursday now and it
becomes absolute chaos I was enthralled
I was like this is the film I mean it's
not the film The film's actually a
completely different style of film which
is a slasher flick but the setup of this
film being executed as a horror film in
which hordes of customers on Black
Friday are just trampling each other I
could personally go for an entire film
of that a Black Friday zombie apocalypse
Vibe horror film as seen and experienced
from customer service employees in a
store because I've been there I've
worked Black Friday it is in fact hell
and people are indeed the worst versions
of themselves but that's just the setup
one year later someone's dressed up on
Thanksgiving and killing people with an
axe I've always had kind of a soft spot
for those post scream 90s or post 9s but
throw them back to the 9s teen slasher
films all trying to be scream and I got
to say un like a lot of those other ones
The Kills in Thanksgiving are actually
pretty awesome they were gory and bloody
but in a fun kind of way not in a Goro
kind of way until later I'll get to it
in a second it has what you expect from
Scream wannabe slasher flick kills but
also with that fun execution of Final
Destination Deaths the stuff that sticks
with you cuz when you see that when
you're driving on the freeway oh you
think of it too how are the
characters they're Canon fod they're
there to die I don't give a [__] about
them probably should but I didn't
they're most interesting when they're
suspects when you're like maybe you're
the killer that's when you give a [__]
about them the most and then you're like
all right maybe not I die for all I give
a [__] which is really a bummer because
usually in a movie like this there's at
least one character you latch on to
you're like you're the one carrying me
through this nope zero [__] given
unless they're getting killed I'm like
oh hey what's up fun then the third act
happens and all things being Eli Roth it
shifts into ridiculous and gross I get
it in terms of execution of the third
act there are things from the fake
trailer that are in here and that's why
they're in here everything leading up to
that was actually a really fun and
bloody slasher flick the third Act was
definitely directed by the guy who
directed hostile not that the third Act
is ever as gross as hostile but it does
have a bit of that Vibe likei Ross like
great but has anyone vomited while their
mouth is gagged in this movie no then we
still got work to do also that third act
does go on for a bit too long I was like
and it's it hasn't ended oh and we're
still going that would have been a nice
ending 90 minutes folks it should have
been 90 minutes internet has it as an
Hour 4 six one thing that probably would
have helped this film when it comes to
cheese and dialogue is that Grindhouse
Vibe film scratches the Distortion to
make it feel like Grindhouse was this
35mm print that just got beat to [__]
and put through the ringer I get why it
wasn't in here because Grindhouse had a
lot of marketing explaining what that
Vibe was and why it is in the movie it's
been a minute since grind outly [__] is
it has it been 16 years I just did the
math if a kid was born then he could
drive now I don't like bye I'm out bye
I'm not going to sleep well I got my
cane right here you darn kids when this
comes out on home release I would love
for there to be a version available that
does have that Grindhouse Distortion
because this movie does have a cheese
factor that lends itself to that both
with dialogue and otherwise I don't know
I I missed the throwback I really liked
Grindhouse and the kind of throwback it
was with the style it had plus a person
and a movie should not forget where they
came from like in the end the fact is
I'm not a big fan of Eli Roth's work
personally his movies are just not my
thing no other way to say it that said
this is absolutely the most enjoyable
Eli Roth film I've seen in about two
decades third act flaws aside the first
couple acts I was really into this thing
if you're an Eli Roth fan you're
probably going to eat up every frame if
you're not an Eli Roth fan the first two
acts might actually surprise you I mean
if you're not an Eli Roth fan but you're
still a slasher flick fan I mean if you
don't like Eli Roth or bloody slasher
movies don't watch this it's just simple
as that like there's no no way around
that I'm going to put this one over the
edge man I'm going to say I had a
surprisingly bloody fun time no alcohol
required I mean it's probably a lot
better with friends and booze so it
probably should be a good time if you're
drunk all right so Thanksgiving have you
seen it what did you think about it
what's your favorite post scream slasher
film '90s and 2000s were littered with
them whatever it is whatever you think
comment below let me know and as always
if you like what you've seen here and
you want to see more click right here to
see
[Music]
more